aaron blair who you may be familiar with
we call him blay
blay has been with me i believe he
started working on the show as an intern
back when the tv show i think was in
black and white
it was a long long time ago and then uh
rose to prominence uh with our online
stuff and uh we did cluelessgamer
together and he's we've been joined at
the hip for a long long time well he
often takes a look at the conan
subreddit and uh there is a new thread a
hearty discussion do you want to hear
the subject i'll admit i'm horrified
okay i don't want to embarrass do you
know what a subreddit is
it's the one that's beneath the reddit
okay yeah in a way you're right yeah all
right
i think conan is so attractive
no wait a minute you said this is a hot
debate no i said that i said a healthy i
don't think i said debate did i say
debate
uh you said a hot topic hot topic making
it
seem like it was something that people
were having a heated discussion yeah you
i sound like well you know
you say tomato i say tomato there are
people out there that think conan's
attractive and then of course just as
many people are firing back i just mean
it's a popular thread hey
see that's nice i've always liked conan
but now i'm starting to think of him as
attractive his personality i mean now
i'm starting to think of him as
attraction you're just growing into it
okay i'm gonna shut up okay go ahead his
personality is amazing and his sense of
humor is great i can't stop watching
videos of him i just think he's so cute
please tell me there's some conan fan
girls out there then the first comment
is come on conan we know this is you
i worked hard disguising myself and
someone's gone as far as to say
i've thought this since i was a teen top
five conan's bearded conan during rider
strike conan showing off his long legs
conan delivering chinese food in nyc
conan playing air guitar does this make
you uncomfortable or do you love this uh
wow let's see um both okay uh how about
that is that a fair answer yeah it's a
sushi roll there's a discomfort of rice
and there's the of course hearty protein
of someone out there likes me
what's that show crazy was it cr crazy
stupid love or whatever what's that the
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah crazy stupid
yeah crazy stupid love with the with
emma stone steve corral
the movie starts
with um and i saw it in the movie
theater and the movie starts with uh
emma stone saying you know i kind of
think conan o'brien's you know is that
right yeah like you know and then
immediately and i was sort of i was in
the movie theater thinking well hello
you know this is
just about to pat myself on the back
and then the character she's talking to
was like what are you talking about
well you think i'd want to mess and then
she says do you think i'd want to mess
her i don't want to mess around with his
ginger junk with what she said
i'm in the theater
and i'm sitting next to my wife
and my wife is like nodding like yeah
trump tell me about it tell me about it
she's there nodding like
my wife yelled out
preach
[Laughter]
amen
been there been there and done that oh
my god yeah and um
so uh yeah i've been uh humiliated many
times come on but you you're focusing on
that but emma stone's character said you
were attracted to her character did come
on but then someone wrote that like why
can't you just be like nice job yeah
it's well done okay yeah
do you agree that to me it's funny that
whenever something like that happens in
my life it's immediately followed by the
other thing not with this
this whole thread is positive
reinforcement in fact it folds in on
itself it says this is the first time
i'm reading this glory reading this
thread to conan on the podcast would be
gold
and then the next comment is as a dude
who loves oh conan and gorly for so many
different reasons please let this happen
yeah yes and then the next comment is
all caps conan in jeggings
oh my god i remember that i remembered i
believe the three the three kardashian
sisters were on that day yeah that i
wore jack i think they were and i walked
out in the hall afterwards and was
talking to them and realized he's
chatting up the kardashians as one does
and uh
it looked like my lower half had been
spray painted with an acid watch
i met conan a few years back i have had
will always have a huge crush on him see
that's something you can't mitigate like
that's that's undeniable what's this
guy's name lindsey graham i was so
i was so nervous that usual lindsay
i was so nervous that my husband had to
really push me to talk to him so i don't
think my hubby has any clue how hot for
conan i am or else he'd be jealous i
mean i've seen it in person though when
we went on tour there were a lot of
people there was a girl and it was in
the documentary where she was wearing a
shirt that said dreaming of bone and
conan oh wow you know how much how hard
it was for me to make that shirt
i sold i made them myself with iron-on
with iron on letters and i sold them in
the lobby myself
yeah with a mustache on so no one
i'd be like uh ladies so uh did you like
most ladies who want to buy this shirt i
had a bad accent you would like at the
bottom with cotton shirts
sometimes it'd be like conan this is so
sad no i'm not the conan man
i am from
the other country
you hadn't even thought your character i
hadn't really given it a lot of thought
i was so busy making the bone in with
conan t-shirts that i i had to get it
out there i gotta share more of these i
mean it goes against all my fiber by
being to give you this joy but he's the
hottest here's another one oh my god omg
is how it was written in full disclosure
i have a huge crush on conan since the
seventh grade i'm in my 30s now and he's
still the hottest celebrity in my book
yeah he's been my crush for 30 years wow
it's gonna it's just it goes on nursing
how old i am no how do you hear that has
been my crush for 75 years this is on
and on about how i've had a crush on
grandma moses
since 1911.
do they mention us at all girls not
really no what is that just crap
yeah
it's okay that's all right yes girl he
is adorbs his personality and
genuineness def helps too heart
[Laughter]
i'm a straight male i think i'd let
conan have his way with me
well now we're getting somewhere
finally
i've had a big crush on conan since i
was 13 14. i'm almost 25 now and i still
have a thing for him some friends of
mine in college would call me conan
after i started talking about my crush
on him lmao i even saw the show live in
2016 and he waved at me i practically
swooned i think if i met him i would die
happy lol wink wink i remember waving at
that audience member oh yeah you're
you're their slash how he's like my love
yeah you're theirs right
who's your big celebrity crush ava green
really yeah she's amazing oh yeah i love
her ava green she was vest berlin yeah
casino right in the face i knew she was
a bond girl yeah in casino royale yeah
she's the best she's uh
google her god she's beautiful and and
honestly to judy greer pascal oh my god
oh oh
tell me about it yeah i mean she's
a beautiful woman
who's also
hilarious and has an amazing personality
yeah i was a little bit nervous when she
was on yeah i could tell yeah she's
pretty yeah he kept um crying
once she tried to touch a strand of her
hair i tried to snip it off
wait who's your who is your crush
uh there's two
just a year there's gotta be like
there's gotta be one oh um there are
okay there are you know i guess it's
different for you because you meet them
and you know them and that's that'd be
clear yeah i am my celebrity crush is
amanda seyfried as
elizabeth holmes
the therapist woman yeah yeah with the
voice yeah yeah i just like do that
voice
put on way too much lipstick
now wear this black turtleneck now try
and convince me you have a system for
measuring uh blood with one drop but
that doesn't work
that's it that's it i love you that's my
official kink that's probably what life
is sex life is like with her if i went
to uh if i went to a dominatrix i would
say uh could you uh could you dress up
as uh they'd be like wait what
who's yours
yeah oh yeah yeah slash i mean before
slash it was jordan knight from new kids
on the block he's the first boy that i
was like oh but then slash was my like i
mean there's no other way to say this he
was my sexual awakening oh that was what
blondie was to me oh really yeah yeah
that's a good one oh my god but that's
the comic strip the old coffins yeah the
comic strip
with dagwood
eating a giant sandwich that was your
crush
no one's going to get that i love
crushes yeah yeah i love having a crush
it was awful but i loved it yeah in the
early days of the late night show i
would have them i mean that's why it's
too many it was just
i was young and these beautiful women
were coming on all the time and they
were i mean i remember the first time
jennifer connolly came on the show oh
yeah and um i had to go and have my eyes
surgically removed
and
because they just came popping out of my
head
i know i just she's so beautiful and
lovely just such a lovely person but
yeah yeah i was getting uh crushes all
the time back in the day the 90s it's
just one long crush-a-thon
but it's all in the past now
for i'm married ladies yeah and i won't
be for long if i keep using this voice
wait you and the theranos woman get
together with those two voices
hello
amanda say freeze elizabeth holmes i
wish to date you
i don't think that's possible
i'm busy working on
this mechanism i dropped out of uh
berkeley after
sophomore
items well i think we'd make a wonderful
couple
i am colonel brand from the 90s you're
amanda seyfried as elizabeth holmes
i must have you
oh okay
but first i need you to invest 40
million dollars
in this very flawed machine that keeps
exploding in walgreens
you're turning me on you
you temptress i want to put some erotic
music under that what a sad sexual
fantasy that's my sexual fantasy conan
o'brien from the 90s
like 93-94 when my voice is up here
because i'm trying so hard to please
and uh
amanda seyfried playing uh elizabeth
holmes
hello who is it
why greetings
portrayal of elizabeth holmes
it's i conan o'brien from the early 90s
i brought you flowers oh if you could
just put those flowers over in the
corner uh i'm working on uh taking apart
this machine that we stole
so that we can turn it into what looks
like a thoroughness machine to defraud
investors well it sounds like an erotic
evening for us
let's get to it i love that turtleneck
it swallows your whole head yeah
[Music]
anyway
you wouldn't happen to have 65 million
dollars
oh you're turning me on i love being
defrauded by you
biographical portrayal
of elizabeth holmes as played by
honestly
i'm close
i'm so close just talk to me a little
more
tell me how it's going to be in every
walgreens
well
the plan
is to have there be a wellness center in
every walgreens
[Music]
that's right that's how conan o'brien
orgasms in 1994
i love my insistence on calling her
dramatic portrayal
it's not a man to say frieda and it's
not elizabeth holmes it's elizabeth
holmes as portrayed by amanda seyfried